direct linear variation let's unpack
each of these three words so that we
know what we're talking about and why it
applies variation variation we start at
the end
I just means when something changes
right so this is about changing
quantities these are quantities that
don't stay the same things like time or
distance or temperature they change they
vary but they vary in a particular way
right at the front here direct this
words a bit weird because I don't see
any reason why it's called direct but
what they refer to because it's directed
indirect which we'll get onto later
direct means that how do they change
they change together that means when one
goes up the other one goes up as opposed
to when one goes up the other goes down
so direct means they change together
they both rise together they both fall
together they change in the same I guess
this is kind of why you've got the word
direct there they change in the same
direction right when one is increasing
the other one will increase when one
decreases the other one would decrease
linear when we say one gets bigger and
the other one gets bigger as well we
mean they get bigger or smaller at the
same rate and when you graph this idea
of things happening at the same rate you
get a straight line so if we put all of
these three things together direct
linear variation is when your quantities
they change both in the same way and at
the same right that's what direct linear
variation means we can write equations
that produce this a direct linear
variation equation or variation equation
for short
looks like something you're very very
familiar with namely miss this is really
simple in fact it's almost like a step
backwards we looked at more complicated
equations than this with like a plus B
hanging out here on the side when you
see a number in front of the X you're
used to seeing an M you're used to
sitting in M what does that mean that
means the gradient so it's like the
steepness of the graph is it going up
really fast or is it going up slowly
well in the context of variation it gets
a new fancy name I'm just telling you it
so that you recognize it in these
questions it's called the constant of
wait for it proportionality it just
captures this idea that if something is
in or if two things are in direct linear
variation then they are proportional to
each other right you've got some of
these some of these they're in the same
ratio every single time okay so if this
is the case one of the ways that you can
know that something is in or two things
are in direct linear variation is if you
have a look at these two values here I
can divide through by X which gives me
this bless you okay what this means is
when you divide a Y by an X you always
get the same number I say always the
same because it is after all a constant
as opposed to these guys which are
variables okay so if you divide one
quantity by the other one less you you
always get the same number let me show
you what that looks like um you can open
up if you haven't already 290 this new
question one together and you'll see how
all these ideas are applied it's cold
should I get the heater in a second I
will in a minute
okay let's scroll down a little bit okay
let's begin right at the top it says
complete this table which shows the
price of packets of pencils so before we
begin you can see what's happening here
the changing quantities are have a look
at them how many packets you buy and the
price that you pay for those pencils so
these two quantities can change because
you can buy more packets you can spend
more money or less okay let's draw up
this table together shall we
we're gonna need to have six columns to
rows so let's draw it up
I'm going to abbreviate it just a little
bit I'm just going to put rather than
the full sentence the full phrase I'm
gonna put n on the top row and dollar
sign P on the bottom row by the way
while we're looking at a situation like
this one of these would usually be
described as the independent variable
while the other one is the dependent
variable which one do you think is the
most natural choice for which ones which
yeah I think probably the most natural
way to think about it is the price
depends on how many packets of pencils
you buy okay so usually we put the
dependent one down here and the
independent one up here so just going to
get this they're vaccinating over there
okay we're going to just try out the
values 1 2 3 4 and 5 and you've got
right in the middle here 4 dollars 50 as
the price that corresponds to that
number of pencils okay so it says
complete this table which shows the
price with no other indication of any
other change like some group discount or
something with that we can assume that
we've got direct linear variation here
you buy more packets of pencils you're
going to have to pay more money for them
so I'm going to use this equation down
here dependent divided by independent
four dollars 50 divided by three four
dollars 50 divided by three what's that
equal to I feel people
sure hold on no one else here did your
ears yeah yep I presume sir thank you
and it can get the door for thanks I
divided through I got this number
what's the special name for this number
in this scheme have a look I've got it
in red it's the it's the constant
because this thing's not going to change
right of proportionality it's constant
because the price of pencil is going to
be the same every time
so I can use this guy to work out
everything else two packs of pencils add
a dollar fifty each will be great well I
don't need to put a dollar sign I
already got one at the front over here
the single packet of pencils dollar
fifty and I can keep on going this is
not complicated to complete okay